hey what's up guys mkbhd here tomorrow
is Nexus 4 day for me and while I'll be
covering the Nexus 4 in full detail as
soon as I get it the lg optimus G here
has been available for a little bit now
and this Optimus G is the older brother
of the Nexus 4 and it's the phone that
the Nexus 4 was based on so before the
wealth of Nexus 4 coverage coming your
way shortly here's a quick video for
those of you who may be locked into an
18 t contract or are considering the
optimus G this is everything you need to
know about it that's different from the
Nexus 4 first of all the hardware
differences and there are only a few of
these both of these have the Snapdragon
s4 pro chip inside two gigabytes of RAM
a 1280 by 768 beautiful IPS display with
some pretty insane viewing angles and
great outdoor visibility and they all
have a relatively square design with
Gorilla Glass on both sides but on the
front the optimus G has an LG logo and
at the bottom these capacitive touch
buttons that do actually blend in nicely
with the front bezel when they're off
the Nexus 4 doesn't have these it uses
on-screen buttons and around the back
the optimus G has a sweet textured
looking pattern surrounding its AT&T
logo and the eight megapixel camera but
the Gorilla Glass really protects this
just fine and the G also has the sweet
power button notification light and that
AT&T LTE radio inside that the Nexus 4
also does not have depending on whether
you have AT&T LTE coverage in your area
or not this could be an awesome choice
next to the HSPA+ only Nexus 4
that being said battery life has been
pretty nice which is a good sign because
it has the same size twenty one hundred
million power sealed battery as the
Nexus 4 and I can easily get a full day
of use with this with about three hours
of screen on time and medium use now
there are also some software differences
between the G and the four starting with
the obvious this is running an LG skin
on top of Android 4.0.4 Ice Cream
Sandwich and it's very comparable in
features to something like TouchWiz on
the very popular galaxy s3 it has a neat
nature-inspired looking lockscreen
that lets you unlock straight to an
application of your choice and it has
stuff like notification bar quick
controls that let you customize stuff
you know you can change the
- toggle Bluetooth NFC or even take
instant screenshots and write on them
with your fingers which is called the
quick memo feature so that's pretty
handy it has the equivalent of the
Galaxy Note 2 feature it's called cue
slide which lets you play a video in the
background while you do other things and
you can adjust the transparency of the
video you're watching on the fly it's
very cool kind of a little bit of
multitasking and it works with videos
that are stored on the device the phone
is of course a great performer with that
Snapdragon s4 pro it rocks benchmarks
like a boss and it's an all-around great
performer feels zippy all through Ice
Cream Sandwich as expected no word on a
jellybean update for it yet but to be
honest the experience is pretty awesome
even without Google now or project
butter although there is one thing while
you can rotate while you're on the home
screen it does redraw all the graphics
almost every single time which is I
thought that was a little bit strange
pretty much everything else so like I
said is the same as the Nexus 4 down to
the dimensions and the camera sensors so
to the people that say the Optimus G is
basically the same as a nexus 4 but plus
AT&T and an LG skin well you're
basically right so there you go guys
it's the lg optimus G it's pretty
awesome and knowing this I am beyond
excited for the Nexus course a thumbs up
if you're ready for those videos and hit
that subscribe button so you don't miss
them they're coming very soon either way
thank you for watching again and I will
talk to you guys in the next video peace
you